let me say a few words that i've written
down
about the olympic games and the
international olympics committee
i'm visiting family has the t-shirt
but i had to pull away to write and to
say these words
because this very video was taken down
by youtube as per the request of the ioc
you know it's serious when a russian
takes time away from family food and
drink i am heartbroken to see continued
incompetence greed and corruption on the
part of the ilc in failing to do as the
olympic charter states to quote ensure
the fullest coverage and the widest
possible audience in the world for the
olympic games end quote
i want to give you two facts first they
do not make most of the videos of the
games available for replay anywhere that
is accessible searchable and
discoverable whether funded by ads or by
subscriptions for example on youtube or
their own service it is not available
anywhere
second in the most absurd violation of
the olympic charter they've uploaded all
of the videos of the 2012 2016 and the
2020 slash 21 olympics to youtube
and they set all of these videos to
private
this results in a situation like my
four-hour conversation that you're
watching now with travis stevens being
taken down due to us including a few
seconds of a small video overlay of
travis's epic match against ollie
bischoff in 2012. this is done
automatically as per the request of the
ioc
i have the video due to having screen
recorded it from 2012.
here you have travis stevens
an olympic silver medalist
someone who spent his entire life
overcoming injuries losses hard weight
cuts periods of no financial
psychological support culminating in the
biggest heartbreak of his career
in this one match
and this match is available nowhere
online not for free not for one million
dollars
our showing short clips of it results in
the ioc taking it down not demonetizing
it taking it down blocking it
the ioc silences this amazing story of
travis stevens of heartbreak that
eventually led to triumph
and there are thousands of stories like
it stories that are supposed to inspire
the world
to me and to billions of others the
olympic games give a chance to celebrate
and to be inspired by the greatest
stories of human flourishing in the face
of hardship and incredibly long odds or
dominance in the pursuit of perfection
at levels previously thought to be
impossible the olympic games inspired
kids
like me to dream and to work hard to
achieve in our own lives the same
moments of magic and greatness
small or big that the olympic games
reveal i believe the members of the ilc
are good people
but people who forgot the dream
the fire that were sparked and burned in
their hearts when they first saw the
olympics as kids
they've allowed the gradual corruption
of their own human spirit and thereby
have robbed the world of this very fire
the fire of the olympic torch
the fire that ought to burn in the eyes
and hearts of kids watching the olympics
today daring to dream daring to be great
please
please do better
the world needs you the world needs the
olympic games
you